was geht ab hier ist herzlich willkommen
zu einer runde squash zusammen mit -
top-leute ich bin franz und ich bin
works
das ist ein wunderbarer spielmodus
wir wollten ein bisschen variieren
eheleute wir spielen heute einen kleinen
challenge und zwar seht ihr vielleicht
im chat mit ducati bei lieblings
youtuber dankeschön erstmal wir spielen
heute umgelegt das ist ja immer eine
kleine challenge und in sky bars wo man
sich ja die ganze zeit unterwirft
dachten wir uns ist das vielleicht sogar
besonders lustig und deshalb spielen wir
so wie wir spielen
genau das abo das nach deutschland ist
dagegen
hast du eine andere schade ich hab mir
ich habe ich noch eine bekommen
darauf kommt was hast du noch india für
mich sehr überschaubares willst du bist
hier schon und rotor perfekt ich
überlege gerade alter irgendwas besseres
muss es auch geben
das ist so schlecht dass equipment ist
auch ein bisschen verwöhnt findet bei
sky wars wenn man so schnell so viel der
atomwaffen bogensport bogen ich habe ja
nicht sein alter aber f2 oder sein
gucken der schon zwei oder drei
verschossene erster kurzer ich habe auch
noch eine party kann ich bestimmt noch
sinnvoll
schade die fast runter gekickt meinen
eiern
ok ich kein bisschen risiko gehen gehen
noch nicht drauf okay okay
dies kann im bogen abgeschlossen haben
meinten sie lassen uns die aliens erneut
auf jeden fall ist ja nicht so dass sie
einfach nur scheiße geschossen haben
gerade sondern sie sind einfach
unglaublich generös danke dafür
ok bald april 18 von der anderen seite
kommen erst noch ja nach scherle aber
kein handy hat zu schnell abgebaut
ja ich weiss nicht genau herkommen das
machen wenn du okay bis zum abbauen das
wird ihm ausräuchern können nicht nur
eine pickenäcker schnell eine scholz
axel diamanten axel scholz axel oehm ist
bisher das agility und geplant ich hab'
ich hab noch becken in rom fischen
ich brenne über ledig das us-quartett
einer oben wartet einer franz forster
nachher vorsicht muss das über ich renne
einmal achtung eingetütet
max ich hatte auch ein wassereimer ich
bin abgehauen
der eine ist auf mich zugelaufen das
leben eines habe ich zu glauben wieder
chat aussieht wo mein gott franz ich
hab's ableger tut ich lebe auch noch
lieber noch der nächste kriegst du dir
alleine
ich will so richtig helden habe wirklich
so jetzt kommt die die meisten hier um
mein gott stets komplett absterben
ja er gehört zu mir gerannt
nichts ist der typ der chat alter
einfach so ein hexer kil yon mir ich hab
sechs spiele hintereinander getötet
das war echt krank der typ dann das war
einer von ihnen von diesem ist die harte
fakten
das war schon mal gut gerettet übrigens
ja das zwar nicht schön
wann ich sie mir ich habe auch keine
gute rüstung alter ich weiß wie bist du
dazu durchmarschiert habe ein papa ja
aber hat sich nicht sehr gut
franz die runde gefällt mir alter recht
gut auch so ich bin so echt investment
abbauen hier vor
und weil mein ganz allein die ganze zeit
so auf einen halb herzen zwei herzen
und dann wirft der typ der uns gerade
eben so generös hat machen lassen
plötzlich sah ich in ruhe das die kirche
ohne spaß
naja gut sie müssen sich nicht daran
halten aber wenn man sagt und sich dann
so zurückhält dann wäre das schon
angebracht ist ein angst fast wünschen
tätig war so eine schöne sky was wunder
wird das screening pilz mit ihrem fest
nachher er eine reine haut einfach ab
gut jetzt angst national braucht ein
bisschen angst alter und drüber gehen in
diesem viel besser clippers wir hier
besser viel besser
was uns warten bis der andere typen noch
kommt dazu oder engländer peter
boudgoust jung hat er mich geschlagen
ich komme ich aber nicht aber nicht
das war verdammt alter okay aber das war
so unglaublich platz mit den sechs
skills und ich kannte ich fand auch
irgendwie hart spannend davor ich weiß
ich sollte man bei sowas noch was dran
hängen weil er weiß dass das jetzt echt
geil wirklich zudem den anfang weil wir
dadurch marschiert sind
ich glaub ich glaube ich nichts mehr
dran okay okay das war's dann
und wir sehen uns